il en direct dans ce gîte et
françois-xavier bellamy eurodéputés les
républicains tête de liste et l'air aux
dernières européennes
bonsoir merci d'être répondre à nos
questions est ce que vous craignez de
nouvelles violences ce soir en banlieue
bien sûr je crois que nous sommes au
coeur d'une crise sanitaire majeure
les français vivent un confinement
difficile et il est absolument
scandaleux que dans ce climat dans ce
contexte déjà si particulier des
irresponsables s'en prenne ainsi aux
forces de l'ordre menacent la vie les
policiers sous un prétexte totalement
fallacieux évidemment la justice doit
passer
elle doit passer y compris pour ce
motard qui diffuse cet appel rappelons
quand même que il est déjà récidiviste
condamné à quatorze reprises récemment
passé sous contrôle judiciaire pour
avoir menacé de mort une personne avec
un hachoir et je crois qu'il y a dans ce
triste parcours et dans les provocations
de cet individu qui se livrerait à
asnières rodéo
lors de cette soirée le confinement
quelque chose qui nous montre que
malheureusement la police n'est pas
assez soutenue dans le travail qu'elle
fait j'espère que le gouvernement mettra
tout en oeuvre pour mettre fin à ces
débordements à ces violences qui sont
absolument inacceptables
le maire ps de clichy-sous-bois olivier
klein estime aujourd'hui sur france info
que le nombre de personnes dans la
nécessité s'accroît avec le confinement
et majida meas messaoudene conseiller
municipal de s'amener à lui déclaré sur
notre antenne que les inégalités
sociales dans les quartiers sont
exacerbées avec la crise sanitaire des
quartiers à que la république a
abandonné depuis longtemps selon lui en
tant qu'élus et l'air les républicains
qui ont gouverné précédemment 1 tout
comme le parti socialiste est ce que
vous vous sentez responsable de ces
tensions
je me permets de rappeler que je n'ai
jamais eu vos gouvernements de près ou
de loin je suis député européen
aujourd'hui et nous essayons de
travailler le plus efficacement possible
pour permettre que l'union européenne
apporte à notre pays des moyens
nécessaires pour faire face à cette
crise évidemment c
ce pèse lourd et je connais ses
quartiers pour y avoir enseigné et j'ai
enseignement m dans le quartier du luth
ouvrière une voiture de la bac a été
prise d'assaut avec des feux d'artifice
je connais cette situation et bien sûr
je mesure l'ampleur de la détresse
sociale qui doit être celle de beaucoup
d'habitants dans ces quartiers où la
politique du logement est aujourd'hui
souvent défaillante trop souvent
défaillante et et où au fond les
dispositifs sociaux ont été fragilisés
par la crise actuelle mais ça n'excuse
rien et la politique de l' excuses doit
évidemment avoir une fin il n'y a aucune
raison de considérer que parce que les
familles ont du mal à se nourrir
cela permet de comprendre que ces
individus se rendre coupable de faits de
délinquance dont les premières victimes
sont d'ailleurs tous ceux qui dans ces
quartiers voudrait vivre paisiblement et
qui espèrent que leur voiture que les
biens qu'ils ont acquis ne soient pas
détruits à l'occasion de ces faits de
violence que nous voyons sur vos images
vraiment comment la peseta plaisir cette
entière qu'est ce que vous préconisez
il n'y a aucune espèce de lien à faire
entre la difficulté sociale à laquelle
il faut évidemment dépendre et bien sûr
on doit pouvoir soutenir les mères qui
font face aujourd'hui à la situation
difficile de beaucoup de familles dans
ces quartiers comme dans le reste de la
france et dans beaucoup de villes de
province
il n'y a aucune espèce de lien à faire
entre cette situation et la fermeté
absolue avec laquelle il faut répondre à
ces délinquance totalement inexcusables
qui est en train de se manifester sont à
prévoir dans notre pays
mais qu'est ce que vous préconisez pour
pouvoir stopper ces violences alors il
faut mettre en oeuvre tous les moyens
nécessaires les moyens de police et
moyens de sécurité et forces de l'ordre
qui doivent pouvoir faire leur métier
malgré le confinement j'espère que le
gouvernement a pris la mesure de ce qui
était en train de se produire
hier encore on nous parlait et c'est la
porte parole du ministère de l'intérieur
qui évoquait des agissent
de faible intensité je ne sais pas si
c'était le signe qu'on avait pris la
mesure de ce qui était en train de se
passer
il faut donc que le gouvernement met
tout en oeuvre pour soutenir les
policiers dans leur travail
il faut bien sûr que la chaîne
judiciaire puisse être activé à son tour
et là aussi quand nous voyons que le
gouvernement a commencé cette crise et
ce confinement
alors que le français étaient enfermés
chez eux pour des raisons très légitime
relâché en dehors de nos prisons des
milliers de personnes des milliers de
délinquants condamnés
je crois que au fond il ya un signal
assez préoccupant pour la sécurité des
français et qu'il est temps que nos
pulsions elle que le gouvernement puisse
réagir pour faire revenir la fermeté
nécessaire à la gestion de cette crise
françois-xavier bellamy emmanuel macron
est en déplacement aujourd'hui en
bretagne il rend visite à la deuxième
ligne les agriculteurs et les personnels
de la grande distribution
opération de communication ou mal
nécessaire selon vous d'abord il est
nécessaire de dire effectivement notre
soutien à tous ceux qui permet à la
france de continuer de tenir
évidemment beaucoup sont aujourd'hui en
télétravail et ne travaille pas moins
pour autant et mais beaucoup continuent
d'aller sur leur lieu de travail je
pense en particulier en effet à tous
ceux qui vivent si difficilement cette
crise je pense à tous ceux qui assurent
l'approvisionnement de notre pays les
personnels des supermarchés la grande
distribution les livreurs je pense aussi
aux agriculteurs aux pêcheurs qui sont
aujourd'hui dans une situation de très
grande difficulté sociale et qui
pourtant continuent leur travail avec
sérieux parce qu'ils ont dans nos mains
notre sécurité alimentaire
je crois qu'il était important il est
bien que le président la république
puisse heures leur rendre hommage
maintenant ça ne se fera pas d'abord
avec du déplacement qui sont donc savons
bien d'abord un moyen de communication
c'est d'abord avec de l'action qu'il
faut venir les soutenir c'est ce que
nous faisons en tous les cas au
parlement européen puisque nous mettons
en oeuvre toutes les aides nécessaires
pour venir apporter le renfort dont ils
ont besoin à nos agriculteurs à nos
pêcheurs et à tout ce qu'ils font
aujourd'hui vivre la chaîne alimentaire
en france pour la protection des
français
mulhouse angers le cas dorcel finistère
le président se déplace beaucoup ont
séparé de confinement est ce qu'il
montre l'exemple selon vous parce que je
confesse que j'ai du mal à comprendre
cette stratégie au fond les français
sont confinés on leur demande de rester
chez eux on leur dit que tous les
déplacements non essentiels doivent être
annulées c'est un effort pour beaucoup
d'entre nous eh bien il est me
semble-t-il aussi nécessaire que chacun
s'applique cet effort à commencer par
les responsables politiques à commencer
par le premier d'entre eux on peut
cultiver les liens étroits avec le
terrain avec les acteurs de terrain sans
pour autant mettre en scène ses propres
déplacements et j'avais été assez
effondré par les images de ce
déplacement un pantin qui avait donné
lieu à un bain de foule
on le sait bien des déplacements
présidentiels suppose de mettre en
oeuvre des moyens humains donc de faire
courir des risques à des gens qui
s'engagent sur le terrain suppose aussi
souvent de réunir du monde
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit le plus
opportun ça ne doit pas être un sujet de
polémique évidemment mes joueurs c'est
le plus important de poursuivre les
actions de communication qui sont
peut-être un peu superflu dans les
moments que nous vivons justement parle
de polémiques en tant qu'élu de
l'opposition comment est-ce que vous
jugiez la gestion de crise
gouvernementale votre collègue damien
abad le président du groupe nc à
l'assemblée nationale souhaite une
commission d enquête parlementaire à
l'automne alors que le chef de l'état
lui dit justement qu'il faut éviter
toute polémique en temps de guerre votre
position est bien le temps de l'enquêté
vient de là bien sûr le temps de
l'investigation pour comprendre ce qui
explique que nous ayons trouvé dans une
si grande difficulté non seulement pour
voir ce qu'ont été les responsabilités
de chacun mais aussi et c'est je crois
le plus important pour nous permettre
d'augmenter la résilience de la
prédation place aux prochaines crises
nous avons vécu pendant tellement
longtemps avec l'idée et c'était ce que
défendent et en particulier le président
de la république et l'idée que
l'histoire et eiffel de progrès qu'il
fallait être en marche vers un avenir
qui serait nécessairement radieux l'idée
que le nouveau monde était forcément
supérieure à l'ancien avec cette espèce
d'orgueil qui consiste
à croire que nous étions désormais au
dessus de toutes les menaces et de tous
les risques
moi je crois et je lis toujours dit je
le disais il y encore quelques mois dans
un livre demeure qui consistait à dire
que la première mission du politique
c'est dans le chaos que l'histoire
restera toujours face aux crises qui ne
manqueront pas de se répéter
la première mission du politique c'est
d'abord de protéger de préserver ce qui
doit l'être pour coercition garder
l'équilibré de ces sociétés dont nous
avons besoin il me semble que tirer les
enseignements de cette liste sera
nécessaire pour nous permettre d'être
plus résistant et plus résilient face
aux crises qui viendront demain c'est le
mot de la fin a remercié françois xavier
à bellamy d'avoir réponse à une question
je rappelle que vous êtes eurodéputés et
l'air tête de liste de votre parti aux
dernières élections européennes